la question est de savoir comment
finances pour l'instant notre moyen de
financement c'est ça passe par les
marchés financiers est aujourd'hui notre
dette comment elle se ventile la manière
suivante 20% de notre dette est à la
banque de france au titre de la banque
centrale européenne on a à peu près 25%
qui sont dans nos banques et le reste
des investisseurs étrangers
donc eux qui détiennent c'était donc la
question est de savoir est ce que
aujourd'hui on arrive à la financer oui
on arrive à la finance et pour pas grand
chose
oui est ce qu'elle nous coûte moins cher
qui est un autre des oui encore une fois
donc aujourd'hui la question est de
savoir si on commence à se poser la
question à cet affreux on arrive à 130
on arrive à 140 et autres bon je vous
rappelle que les déficits américains au
sortir de la seconde guerre mondiale
lorsque on était dans une situation
certes ce n'est pas comparable parce
qu'il ya pas de destruction mais quand
même on comprend une situation
particulière avait dépassé les 23 24 %
des déficits amec est on est on sait pas
dit ouh la la qu'est-ce qui se passe on
avait un effort de guerre à fournir
point c'est tout ce qu'il fallait faire
là aujourd'hui si on commence à être
petit bras on va dire ah non au ca
commence à reprendre sur le chômage
partiel en va être moins généreux
on va commencer à faire du bricolage et
on va pas être dans un soutien massif et
bien les effets de la crise vont se
multiplier
et n'oublions pas que le fondement d'une
politique économique c'est être une
garantie d'activité voilà c'est une
garantie d'activité et pour moi c'est ça
qui est essentiel il ne pas confondre
les objectifs intermédiaires les
objectifs finaux les objectifs
intermédiaires
c'est le déficit et là j'ai les
objectifs finaux c'est la croissance et
l'emploi
donc il faut pas que les objectifs
intermédiaires mangent les objectifs
finaux et donc le gouvernement doit
avoir comme boussole uniquement la
croissance et l'emploi et aussi penser
au futur c'est à dire pas forcément
rester dans le même type d'économie
préparer cette transition énergétique
nécessaire lutter contre les inégalités
et la donne est un véritable horizon de
projets à cette société et pas
simplement de dire que c'est une bagarre
comptable pour un point de déficit ou
moins déficit ou plus de dette
la vraie question c'est de garantir
l'activité et faire en sorte que notre
économie
[Musique]
et bien ne s'effondre pas